Republican senator John Kennedy weighed
in on the debt ceiling debacle that's
going on right now negotiations
discussions Republicans wanting to
leverage the debt ceiling to push for
spending cuts even though spending cuts
should happen when you're weighing
spending not weighing fulfilling your
financial obligations all of that has
been uh discussed but I want to take a
look at a moment with the Republican
senator John Kennedy appearing on Fox
News and making a point about
the debt and then we'll respond to it
very fascinating stuff here take a look
if you're going to have a party
you have to put the band
if you're going to borrow money
you have to pay it back
that's true as a moral principle and a
principle of practicality
and you you don't you don't have to be a
senior at Caltech to figure that out
now here's the truth part
Congress had a spending party
more specifically the house Democrats
not the House Republicans
the Senate Democrats and a whole lot of
Senate Republicans had a spending party
I didn't vote to do it
I would have been happy with a couple of
beers after work
it's I don't know how that lasts
sentence connects to what he was saying
honestly maybe I missed something but
let's just take this as an opportunity
to discuss this myth that Democrats are
the irresponsible Spenders they run up
the debt and the deficit Republicans
have to go in there and clean up the
mess and you hear it all the time and I
was actually hitting
um or sitting I should say at a dinner
last night with a friend talking about
how it's almost impressive the
Republicans despite the facts not being
on their side have convinced so many
people that they are better for the
economy which we know not true and uh
are more financially responsible with
spending they don't run up the deficit
as much and let's just go through a few
pieces I've come across over time that
kind of illustrates this
is not the case as this New York Times
op-ed rights the Democrats juice the
economy by spending money and then leave
Republicans to clean up the mess over
the last four decades in fact Republican
presidents have run up larger deficits
than Democrats another piece here from
towards data science while Republicans
often claim that they are the more
fiscally responsible party my research
suggests otherwise compared to
democratic presidents Republicans are
estimated to add between
0.75 and 1.2 percent more to the deficit
as a percent of GDP each year they are
in office and then we'll look at one
final chart here that shows you the
deficit change whether up or down over
time and of course the reason why we're
speaking in terms of deficit is when
you're looking at fiscal year after
fiscal year
one president would come into power and
we refer to the presidential
um party who's in the white house
because that's the easiest to understand
Congress could be any which way but the
end of the day things have to get signed
off for the most part
um by the president and he kind of holds
authority over his party through that
process and so we can measure it that
way and what we see is actually
Republicans as this chart shows have
jacked up the deficit Democrats have
often decreased it and because Biden's
presidency is only halfway through we
don't have a whole lot of information
to share on that yet but
as I was saying the reason why we talk
in terms of deficit is the debt is just
accumulating it's just on and on and on
and on it gets bigger and bigger and so
saying that this president
was president when the debt was at its
largest is kind of pointless because
even if they got in office and the debt
increased one penny then
they would have the largest debt in
American history that's not really
valuable whereas the deficit is
understanding how much of the budget is
spending Beyond what's being brought in
in taxes right so that's how much each
year is being spent beyond what the
government is actually bringing in taxes
and that's where you can understand is a
Democrat decreasing that deficit and
bringing down how much more we're
spending or are they increasing and
often Republicans are actually doing
that more are actually increasing the
deficit more contributing than
um
compared to GP and compared to their
time as president more to that scary big
number that the Republican Party likes
to fearmonger a lot about so John
Kennedy there that's just giving you a
historical context because we hear that
talking point so often and if you're in
interpersonal conversations where it
comes up that Republicans are better for
the economy and they're better for
um the debt or whatever it might be we
just understand that's not factual and
even especially with the economy example
as you dive into more and more specific
bits of data you realize how much of a
trend this is that under democratic
presidents even if you control for
Congress and different times based on
crises still Democratic presence are
better for the economy and then we're
looking here
better for the deficit so these branding
items that Republicans have been able to
use so effectively are so often just so
dishonest and so right there John
Kennedy honestly should just think more
about his own party because clearly
historically Democrats aren't the ones
with the problem find me on Twitter Luke
pbsley